Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute
Papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
In 2021, scientists at Google had an absolutely
insane idea. Do you see this photo? Yes? They
said, now, let’s give this to the AI, and ask
it to fly into this photo. Insanity. And yet,
it worked like this. Absolutely
amazing. It was not given a video,
and not even a collection of
photos. Just this one photo.
However, there is a problem. Do you see the
problem? Well, this is the problem. Yes,
if we look for a while, it has to come up
with newer and newer content, and over time,
the consistency of the results suffer.
We don’t get one coherent landscape,
but something that morphs into
something else not connected to it.
And today, this is why I am so excited to show
you NVIDIA’s new paper on video generation. Let’s
see…yes, they promise exactly what we are
looking for. Better long-term consistency!
So first, let’s see what previous techniques
can do and then, what this new one can.
This is an excellent test case. Now, you may
be asking Károly, what in the world is this?
And I say that is exactly the point.
MoCoGAN-HD is a technique from 2021,
from just 2 years ago, and we cannot
even tell what it is trying to do.
Here is a later work from 2022, the time-agnostic
time-sensitive transformer TATS in short. This
isn’t great either, but now, at least we see
what it is trying to do. And that is rendering
clouds. It starts out reasonably well, but as
you see, the results quickly start degrading,
and that is the point of today’s video.
Long-term consistency is super difficult. DiGAN,
another work from last year does
way better than these previous two,
great progress, but as you see,
the video is full of artifacts.
And now, hold on to your papers Fellow
Scholars and let’s see the new technique!
Holy mother of papers! Do you see that?
It is leaps and bounds beyond any of these
techniques. And all this just one more
paper down the line. How cool is that?
I don’t know about you, but I am itching to see
more examples. Let’s compare against StyleGAN-V,
one of the state of the art techniques out there
for this task. First, horseback riding. I must
say it is pretty incredible that today, an AI is
capable of creating a video like this. However,
there are issues. Things morph in and out of
existence, and did you notice? This doesn’t really
synthesize new scenery, it just repeats this jump
over and over. Now let’s see the new technique.
Wow! Now we’re talking! After that first jump,
we get new scenery as we enter the forest.
But it has even more advantages. Look, when
synthesizing a landscape, I have a much better
sense of camera motion and rotation with the
new technique than with the previous one.
And it can do something even better too. Yes,
this is going to be everyone’s favorite. Super
resolution. What is that? The enhance thing.
First, it generates a coarse video, and then,
adds more and more detail to it until it becomes
a much sharper, higher resolution video. Just
look at the difference. It takes no more than
a heap of pixels that looks like a computer
game from 25 years ago, and it understands what
this scene is meant to portray, and it creates
this detailed version of it, and I would argue it
would do at least as well as a human would. Wow.
So, clearly, the new technique seems way
better, but this is a research paper,
in which scientists at NVIDIA also have to show
mathematically that it is better. So how do they
do it? How do they measure the differences? Well,
first, at the risk of simplifying the measurement,
we show these videos to a neural network that
somewhat mimics the perception of humans. And
the lower the score it gives, the better. And…oh
my goodness. Look at that. Apart from a few, super
low-resolution cases, this new technique is so
much better than the previous methods. Incredible.
But there is another way of measuring which
is exactly better, and even more importantly,
by how much. And that is, of course,
showing these videos to humans and asking
them. In the user study, 500 people
were asked which is more realistic,
and about 80-85% of the people chose the new
technique over StyleGAN-V, the previous one.
That is incredible. And once again, all this
progress in AI research in less than a year.
Now, clearly the new technique is not
perfect either, it has artifacts, morphing,
and other issues as well. However, this is
incredible progress in just one paper. And,
as always, as a wise Fellow Scholar, please invoke
the First Law of Papers, which says that research
is a process. Do not look at where we are, look
at where we will be two more papers down the line.
So, finally, better long-term
consistency for AI-generated
videos. What a time to be alive!
Also, good news! The source code,
datasets and pretrained models for this paper
are available, so let the experiments begin! So,
what video you would generate using this
technique? Let me know in the comments below!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!